حرب روسيه الهجينه ضد اوكرانيا تاثيرها
يمثل الحرب الفعلي طعن الارض فمع استمرار
القتال الفعلي يظل الفضاء الالكتروني
مصرحا الثانويه للحرب العام الماضي كان
شاهد على ذلك تضاعفت الهجمات الالكترونيه
الروسيه على اوكرانيا ثلاثه اضعاف تمكنت
كيف خلاله من التصدي لاكثر من 4,500 هجوم
الالكترونيه
هجوم في عام 2021 و8 هجوم الكتروني عام
وهو قطاع الطاقه والخدمات اللوجستيه
والمنشات العسكريه فضلا عن قواعد البيانات
الحكوميه غالبا تتخذ الهجمه الروسيه شكل
البرامج المدره وفي بعض الحالات يمكن ان
تسبب ضرر جسديا مباشره او غير مباشر تستغل
موسكو حرب
لتغطيه اهدافها ومخططاتها عسكري
سيناريو استخدم نوفمبر الماضي حين نفذ
القراصنه 10 هجمات يوميا شلت البنيه
التحتيه الحيويه الاوكرانيه لعيبه روسيا
على تنسيقها جبتها الالكترونيه مع
عملياتها المعلوماتيه والنفسيه والدعايه
المضاد
ليس فقط اليك المقاتلين على الارض فلديها
اسطول العسكري من قراصنه الاستخبارات
والمحترفين
[موسيقى]
على الضفه الاخرى تحذرني
عبر هجمات القرصنه على البنيه التحتيه
للمعلومات الحيويه في حين تعمل الدول
الغربيه على ايجاد طرق الدفاعيه لمواجهه
التهديد السيد راديو الروسي